[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily bill cosby tries
to get his conviction for sexual assault
overturned we speak to attorney gloria
allred on how his accusers feel about
the appeal
and questions still surround the death
of actress brittany murphy 11 years
after her passing
renowned forensic pathologist dr cyril
weck weighs in
plus jailhouse staff tracking an
inmate's movement
in the ceiling how teens attempted a
wild escape
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian bachmeier along with terry
austin
convicted sex offender and former actor
and comedian bill cosby
is attempting to overturn his conviction
cosby's attorneys argued before the
pennsylvania state supreme court
that he didn't receive a fair trial the
83-year-old is serving three to ten
years
sentence at a state prison he was
convicted of three counts of sexually
assaulting
andrea constand in 2004. the key issue
for repeal
is the trial judge's decision to allow
other accusers to testify
about uncharged prior bad acts by cosby
the judge is expected to reach a
decision
at a later date attorney gloria allred
represents 33 of the accusers
and joins me here now thank you for
joining us today gloria
thank you for inviting me brian now
gloria as i said you represent three of
the uncharged bad act witnesses
uh janice kinley uh elise leuven and uh
shalom lashan and a large part of what
we heard today in the hearing
was the judge deciding whether or not
these witnesses should have testified
at this second trial what are your
responses to those arguments
yes and and you just showed janus uh in
the single shot
uh that uh and i did represent all three
they were the majority of the prior bad
act witnesses in the
second criminal case also represented
and that's lee slot lublin
i also represented one uh the only one
of the prior bad act witness
who was allowed to testify in the first
criminal case
against mr cosby and that was a case in
which there was a mistrial because the
jury was split they couldn't decide
whether mr cosby should be found guilty
or should be acquitted
so there was a mistrial but the
prosecution refiled the case and the
second time
the judge the same judge who had allowed
only one
prior bad act witness in the first case
allowed five
in the second case i think the argument
this morning
uh was obviously very important uh
the i mean the test brian always is
is the admission of the testimony more
probative than prejudicial or is it more
prejudicial
than probative of course the defense
argued
that it was more prejudicial than
probative
of course all evidence that presented by
the
prosecution against the defendant is
always prejudicial to some extent in
other words it would tend to
argue that there should be a conviction
but the prosecution argues
here it was more probative than
prejudicial
more likely to lead to the truth about
what happened
and that is why they wanted to admit
and did ask to have admitted the
testimony of prior bad act witnesses
it was as a form of corroboration for
andrea constant who was the only victim
for whom charges had been filed yeah
now i know there's going to be a i have
a few more questions about the hearing
today but i kind of want to leap ahead a
little bit
uh bill cosby was sentenced to three to
ten years uh two years ago
and there's a potential that he could be
released as early as september 25th
of 2021. uh what does this potential
parole date mean for for you as an
attorney but also
the the accusers and victims that you
represent
well i mean the question is is he going
to be
released or not i think he was sentenced
to three to ten years so he's eligible
for parole on the date that you
mentioned uh or at some time in
in 2021 however he has consistently said
he feels no remorse uh he's not
essentially taking any responsibility
because he says he's innocent
of what he was convicted of three counts
of aggravated indecent sexual
assault so whether if he's showing no
remorse
uh whether the parole board will in fact
grant him parole
i don't know i think my clients just
want justice to be done so we'll have to
see
what form justice takes if any
and i'm assuming you heard some of the
arguments uh this morning
between both sides what are some of your
reactions perhaps to
the defense attorneys representing bill
cosby and how they articulated or
colored the second trial of course one
of their arguments brian is
that allowing five uh prior bad act
witnesses
to testify is in a sense asking that
there be five
mini trials and that of course the acts
that were testified to uh by
these five other prior bad act witnesses
they were not you know they were not
reported to law enforcement the defense
argues
and uh so that they're more prejudicial
than probative but of course the
prosecution would argue
that uh yes that's true they weren't
reported to law enforcement but they did
tell others about it maybe it was a
family member maybe it was a friend
uh and anyway the prosecution argues
look it's important
on the issue of consent absence of
mistake
and that means that they wanted to prove
that cosby who they argued said that
andrea consented
to drugging or sexual assaulting and so
it wasn't sexual assault according to
cosby's team
that she consented that by showing the
testimony allowing the testimony of
prior bad act witnesses
it shows that mr cosby was not mistaken
about whether andrea consented because
look
look at the testimony of the prior bad
act witnesses
if he is drugging on sexually assaulting
other women he knows that if a woman is
incapacitated by alcohol or drugs
she can't consent he's not mistaken
about it
he's doing it so that they can't reject
uh him in other words not consent or
consent
they're incapacitated and that is why
they wanted to show it that and of
course
because they want to prove a common plan
scheme or design that mr cosby had
yeah and you're giving us like basically
a law school
exam here because that's when you're
allowed to use this type of evidence for
motive identity common scheme of plan so
gloria all right i want to thank you
very much for lending us your time and
coming on with us to break this down
and i wish you all the best of luck and
happy holidays going forward and you too
brian and
to all your viewers thank you thank you
and now for our own in-depth analysis on
the case joining us now is terry austin
terry a state appellate court already
turned down
cosby's legal team's objections is this
hearing
i mean in your eyes a bit of a long shot
you know i think it is and i'm hoping it
is actually and i think that
you know ms allred really broke it down
for us in terms of
use of the prior bad acts i think it is
showing a scheme and a plan the fact
that he
drugged these women but i think the
other issue here that they
argued was the fact that this deposition
and this concerns me a little bit more
was used and he was told that it
wouldn't be used against him so maybe
his constitutional rights
were violated so that's an issue i think
we need to keep an
eye on as far as this appeal is
concerned yeah it's going to be
interesting when i
listen to the hearing i get it i hear
the arguments but this final piece of
whether or not it was a mistake that
could be overrun by the fact that
there's so much evidence against him
i think that might be something that the
uh
the the state finds himself successful
here thank you very much for that terry
and to you guys still ahead on the law
and crime daily wild courtroom moments
and a dramatic jailhouse video
season three of court cam is premiering
on the a e networks
and we have an inside look and the
sudden death of actress brittany murphy
is still puzzling investigators
what one forensic expert has to say
about the case
next
[Music]
[Music]
this month will mark 11 years since
actress brittany murphy died at the age
of 32.
a podcast looked at the case recently
angela levy is here with what a
legendary forensic pathologist is saying
about her untimely death anjanette
brian you know the deaths of britney
murphy and her husband just five months
apart has sparked a lot of speculation
over the years
a new episode of the podcast red carpet
rendezvous
looks to clear up some of that now
autopsies conducted on brittany murphy
and her husband revealed that both died
from pneumonia
and an overdose of cough medicines
monjack simon won jack's mother wants
more answers about what led to her son
and daughter-in-law dying at such a
young age
testing of murphy's hair showed it
contained several medals which has led
to internet speculation that she may
have been poisoned
lauren conlon interviewed dr cyril west
about the deaths
he re-examined them he does believe that
it
was it was pneumonia and it was neglect
because he made it very clear to me
that the type of pneumonia that brittany
and simon both had
you take an antibiotic and it's
treatable and then you're good to go
so you know it's a mystery why nobody
went to the doctor
to take care of this
now dr wecht said he actually reviewed
these deaths
and the cases associated with them
because
brittany murphy's father contacted him
and wondered why his daughter's hair
contained so many different types of
metal
dr wex said that could have actually
come from hair dye
and he does not believe that britney
murphy was poisoned
there were multiple metals found
in the hair number one if you're going
to poison somebody
why would you have to use four or five
or six different metals
if you're going to do it you'll choose
one number two
if for some reason you decided that you
wanted to use multiple levels
where would you get them number three
these levels in the hair indicated that
they had been there for a while things
do not grow out in the hair immediately
it takes time and therefore
if she had been poisoned then we would
have seen
manifestations of that previously
now dr wecht is pretty critical of
brittany murphy's mother
sharon murphy he says that she had a
duty to seek some type of medical care
for her daughter
the home that they were all living in
has been described as filthy and
brittany
murphy was malnourished
remember the the whole thing there as i
recall they had multiple
security posts and guards and signals
and signs and electronic things and so
on
these people were you know they were
shooky that wonderful jewish word
they were crazy you know they're crazy
they're crazy and yeah and that's the
way they live
and dr wett says that simon manjack also
had a duty to seek medical care
for his wife brian and janet so
what's shared murphy's explanation for
this
you know we would really like to know
you know sharon murphy has not spoken
publicly
about her daughter's death and the death
of simon manjack in many years she also
said back in 2013 in the hollywood
reporter there was an editorial that she
wrote and she said that any
claim that her daughter was murdered was
absolutely ridiculous
she believed that brittany murphy's
father was trying to profit off of this
theory we don't know exactly what sharon
murphy would say about all of this today
we know there was a lot of prescription
drug use going on
in that home we don't know if that
contributed to her lack of action with
her daughter's health
i've reached out to sharon murphy or at
least attempted to do so and have not
been able to reach her
all right thanks angenette we'll make
sure to keep an eye on that for any
upcoming developments
and for legal analysis in the case terry
austin joins me
terry there's a lot of things going
around in this case but
there's no actual criminal charges as a
as an attorney
what are we to look for to begin this
criminal investigation or maybe even
charges
well brian first of all evidence we need
evidence this case is really
missing i think some key evidence we
don't have
anything to say that there was a crime i
do think there was a crime to tell you
the truth because
i don't believe in you know coincidences
but
here they're going to have to find some
forensic evidence to say
that it was really tied back to sharon
the mother or anybody else for that
matter because it does seem like to me
this was maybe you know the mold in the
house or pneumonia but it is very odd
yeah there's a lot of smoke but it seems
we're still trying to find that fire
it appears and as the saying goes where
there is smoke there's often fire but
we'll have to wait till see thanks terry
and after the break we take you
inside the ohio courtroom of a murder
trial involving a fake pizza order
did the jury get it right plus a daring
escape in how the fleeing suspects were
caught
the video you don't want to miss after
this
[Music]
welcome back trust me i know teens can
be
let's say adventurous sure but ones at a
nashville detention center planned an
especially daring escape
long crime founder and host of the tv
show court cam has the video
first we go to the juvenile justice
center in nashville tennessee
it's after 9 00 p.m four teens aged 15
to 17
have been left unsupervised while on a
work detail
off camera in the basement of the
building as minors these boys are
staying here instead of jail
while they await trial for crimes
including armed robbery
auto theft and murder
and as you can see they don't plan on
sticking around for their trials
they've just come up a basement elevator
and are wearing what appear to be yellow
security vests
while one of the young men begins making
his way down the hall
he changes his mind and follows the
others up the stairs
when they get to the ground floor the
teens bolt through the front entrance
no one's stopping them
cameras catch the entire escape for now
they've made it and run off into the
night
eventually all four involved in the
escape were caught and could now face
additional charges
it's later discovered that the four
teens likely had help from the inside
two employees are terminated and
arrested for assisting the juveniles in
their escape
and this wasn't the first time a
juvenile tried to escape
this exact same juvenile facility
we go back just two years earlier
these staff members have been tracking a
teen as he makes his way through the
ceiling
just a few feet above their heads
[Music]
though he's just out of reach the
ceiling begins to give way
[Music]
the ceiling doesn't hold and the
defendant crashes through
security's not giving up and immediately
surround him
as his daring though poorly planned
escape
comes to an end watch again
as the juvenile makes one last effort to
flee
but security's taking no chances of
letting him escape again
he's unhurt and immediately taken back
into custody
after this incident and the most recent
escape
the city of nashville is considering
taking over operations
of the privately run center
i think it might be time to find someone
else around those detention centers
but when we come back an ex-husband says
his former wife is guilty
but he's already the one behind bars
we're giving you a closer look into an
ohio trial
did this woman get away with murder for
seven years
an ohio man in the middle of a deadly
love triangle is pointing the finger
at his ex-wife for killing his
ex-girlfriend
chad cobb pled guilty to murdering
ashley biggs a retired army veteran and
pizza delivery driver
biggs was found dead in her car in a
cornfield cobb later implicated erika
stefanko
who he divorced him after his arrest
cobb claims to fanco place a fake pizza
order at domino's to lure biggs to her
death
cobb says that he was outside next to a
tree and watched as
biggs pulled up to where they were
waiting
with everything that was going on
looking back
she wasn't happy to see me that's
for certain what did you do with
ashley's body when
i had to leave i picked her up and
put her in the car whose car ashley's
car
in the back seat and when you put her in
the back seat
did she have anything on her that that
was placed on her
that she didn't have on her when she
arrived
yes there was a zip tie how many
i only remember one i remember one
around her neck
on cross examination cobb insisted he's
not the killer
he was ashley in her car
when i drove it to our bridge
in in the field yes yes sir
was ashley already dead yes sir
did you strangle i am not the one that
strangled her sir
i see so now you plead guilty
and now you're saying that you didn't
kill her is that right
yes sir you drove the car to the far end
of a
cornfield correct yes sir
that cornfield was pretty far off the
road true yes sir
i i don't know how uh how
far but uh decent walk
the defense pointed out that cobb only
implicated stefanko
after she filed for divorce from him
leaving him for his friend and former
boss
sir the time and still currently
i'm under a life sentence so them
getting married really
neither here nor there i mean one part
did you and erica
ever plan to kill
ashley biggs no sir
at your sentencing when judge jones
asked you if you had anything to say
did you say anything about
erica i told the judge
that there is a lot that i need to say
about this but there's very little that
i can
mr cobb yes sir i'm asking you
specifically
at sentencing terry appeals are always a
possibility do you see a possible issue
here
in chad cobb's testimony i don't i think
he contradicted himself but as you know
the potential grounds for appeal are
legal error
jury misconduct or ineffective
assistance of counsel and that does not
exist here
yeah i can see that here as well but
broader than that just quickly any other
appeal issues other than just chad cobb
yeah i mean i think the jury is confused
by chad cobb's testimony because the
fact that you know he
in fact said he did kill and then he
said he didn't
but no i don't think there's any
appealable grounds and i think the jury
came out with the right decision here
yeah it's going to be interesting to see
how this plays out of course erica
stefanko was found
guilty of the same charges of her as her
ex chad cobb all we're waiting for now
is the sentence
if you remember the death penalty is not
on the table so potentially life for a
lifetime of the possibility of parole
terry as always thank you for joining us
and thank you for joining us here on the
law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you